[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: So, good morning.
Welcome to our session on what's
new in Android development
tools.
My name is Jamal Eason.
I'm here with Xav and Tor.
And today we're
going to give you
an insider's tour of all the
new and upcoming features
for Android development.
As you know, Android
Studio is the official IDE
for developing apps for
Android, provided by Google.
We work hand-in-hand
with the platform
to ensure that all the latest
APIs and features are tightly
integrated inside
of Android Studio.
It's our team's
mission to ensure
that we provide the latest and
greatest tools to help you be
efficient and Thank developers.
I must say, I thank
you for your feedback
so far in making
Android Studio great.
So before we jump
into new features,
I just want to spend a few
moments talking about features
that we launched since we
last spoke with you last year,
in case you missed them.
So last year at IO, we gave
you a preview of Android Studio
2.2, which included things
like a new layout editor,
the Espresso Test Recorder,
and CMake support,
which is great for C++ projects.
And, around
November, we give you
a preview of Android Studio
2.3, which included things
like an update to Instant
Run, the Lint Baseline
support, and the
ConstraintLayout
reaching stable status,
which is tightly
correlated with
the layout editor.
And just this past
March, we actually
released a few releases
of Android Studio 2.4.
But, as you know
from yesterday, we're
not going to be releasing
Android Studio 2.4.
Instead, we're releasing
Android Studio 3.0.
[APPLAUSE]
So we made the shift
for two reasons--
number one, as we were
developing features,
we realized all the work
going inside this release
didn't seem sort of indicative
of one incremental change.
Number two, we made the
tough and rare decision
to make a breaking,
Gradle API change.
And we'll talk about that.
But that change allows
us to scale and have
faster Gradle build speeds.
So we have features
across the entire range
of feature sets for
your app development--
from building, testing, and
optimizing your application.
So let's dive in.
Instead of me
talking about it, I'm
actually going to
invite Tor up to give us
a demo of all the cool features
inside of Android Studio 3.0.
And, after that,
I'll have Xav come up
and talk about the build system.
So with that--
Tor-- let's get started.
TOR NORBYE: All right.
So this is Android Studio 3.0.
It's based on the latest
version of IntelliJ--
the latest stable version--
2017.1.
So we picked up tons
of great features
that I'm not going
to have time to show.
I'll just highlight a couple.
There's parameter hints--
which you see here--
where we show the parameter
name at the call site.
And there's emojis in comments.
You know, so
sometimes, when you're
commenting on some
slow code, you really
want to use a snail emoticon.
All right.
Anyway, the big news for us is
that we are supporting Kotlin,
so--
in the new-- yeah--
[APPLAUSE]
So in the new project wizard,
there's a checkbox now.
You can enable Kotlin
right from the get-go.
Or, in an existing
project, you can start
creating Kotlin files directly.
And the IDE will walk you
through upgrading your project
dependencies.
Or you can just take
an existing class
and run it through a converter.
So the way you do that
is you go to code,
convert Java file
to Kotlin file.
It runs it through
this converter.
And, sometimes, it does a
fantastic job-- like here,
it's realized, I want
string interpolation.
And it's used de-structuring
declarations here.
But, you know, you can see
also sometimes gets warnings.
It's not always perfect.
I want to lower
expectations a little bit.
Here's another example-- here
we have a data class in Java.
There's a one-line version of
this you could write in Kotlin.
But if you run it
through the converter,
you end up with code that
is completely accurate
but not the most optimal.
So this does the same
as before in Kotlin.
So it's really a
great starting point.
And then, typically, you
massage it a bit more.
So here's a Kotlin file showing
several language features.
You have the
four-loop with ranges.
You have a let
statement, with a lambda,
and you have a when statement.
We don't have time to
cover the language today.
There's going to talks
about that tomorrow
that you don't want to miss.
But when you're
starting out, you
might have some concerns
about performance here.
You know, like, is this
going to be expensive?
What about this let statement?
Is this making a new
inner class in an object?
There's a really
great way to find out.
So you can invoke the
show byte code window.
This is going to show the byte
code for the current statement.
If you read byte
code, that's great.
But if you don't, there's this
really great decompile button
in the top right window here.
When I click on this, I get
the equivalent Java code.
So now I can look
at this and go, OK,
that range loop turns
into a really pure y
loop with an index check.
And, similarly, the let
statement is just an if check.
So don't prematurely
optimize in your head
based on what you are
afraid Kotlin's going to do.
Write, you know, the most
beautiful Kotlin code you can.
And when you're in doubt, you
can check what it's doing.
The last thing I'm going
to say about Kotlin
is that all the Android
link checks that ran on Java
files-- there's
about 80 of those.
They're all running
on Kotlin as well.
There's no gap.
It's the same code base now.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Let's talk about
the Layout Editor.
So we launched the new Layout
Editor last year at IO.
And we've continued
working on it, obviously.
So one of the things we have
in the new version is better
handling of errors--
as you can see here--
and constraint layout.
We've enhanced that a lot.
So, first of all, we
recently added chains.
So a chain is a
way to distribute
widgets along an axis.
So you can select
these three widgets--
say that I want to create, for
example, a horizontal chain.
I don't know if you
can see, but there's
kind of a beautiful
chain graphic here.
And I can align
this horizontally.
And now there's this
chain cycle button.
So I can basically
click on this to explore
how the chains are behaving.
Another feature
we're about to launch
is Constraint Layout 1.1.
And in 1.1 we have barriers.
And the easiest way to explain
this is just to show it,
I think.
And so, if I were
to move this widget,
you can see that this
line next to it--
basically, we make sure that
we don't ever overlap with it.
So this is a pretty
good way to make
layouts that respond correctly.
And that's actually
all I'm going
to say about constraint
layout, because there's
a whole talk about it
in a couple of hours
that you don't want to miss.
Another feature we've
added in the Layout Editor
is support for sample data.
So in your apps you might
have for your recycle view.
It's pretty common.
And it looks nothing like the
Layout Editor when you run,
because you're putting data
into it-- images and, of course,
application-specific data.
So a couple of
years ago, we added
some support to deal with
this with design time
attributes-- the tools
attributes, right?
So you could put some
string in and you
can start approximating what
your app is going to do.
But that's terrible
in a list view.
So we've continued
enhancing this.
So now we have this new
sample resource type.
So, for example, I can pull
in some lorem ipsum text.
Or I can pull in, let's
say, date of the week.
But the real power of
this is when you actually
define your own data.
So here is this new
JSON file that I've
created in my project.
This is for a fitness app.
So there's various
activities that, you know,
this app is modeling--
biking, walking, and so forth.
And there's some other data
associated, like distances.
And we even have some icons.
What I can do now is
go into my item layout
that I'm using in the list and I
can start binding these things.
So code completion works
here for the app sample tag.
It's picking out all the
attributes from the JSON file.
And I can, for example, hook
up the icon property to this.
I can hook up the
description property
to this next text view.
And so, when I
come back to this,
you can see I get
a layout that looks
much more like the real app.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
The last Layout Editor
feature I'm going to show
is support for O
downloadable fonts.
So in O, you can declare
There's lots of advantages.
And there's a talk about
that, as well, of course.
But the way this works is
that I select a text view
and in the Layout Editor,
in the font family chooser,
there is a more fonts
item on the bottom.
When I invoke that, I can browse
the available online fonts
or search.
I can pick my favorite--
Fingerpaint.
And you can see, I now get this
new font resource in my project
and it actually works
the way you'd expect.
All right.
Another O feature we've added
is support for adaptive icons.
So in the image asset wizard,
we now help you create these.
So we help you with
the foreground layer.
You can modify the
background layer.
I don't know if you can
tell from the screen,
but there's also options to show
safe zones, grid, and so forth.
So this, hopefully, helps
you put all the right bits
in the right places.
Another small feature
that's easy to miss
is the bottom right corner here.
There's a device
explorer now, finally.
So here you can go in
and actually explore
files in your file system.
You know, you can click on
files to see them locally.
And you can right-click on
folders to upload and download
files and that kind of thing.
All right, let's talk about--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Let's talk about Instant Apps.
So we have a lot of
support for Instant Apps.
We have a bunch
of new lint rules.
We have support in the
Gradle build system, which
I think Xav will talk about.
We have new wizards for
creating feature modules.
But the hardest part of
creating a Instant App
is probably going to be to
break up your monolithic app.
So we're working on
some refactoring tools
to help with that.
So I'm going to take this
simple example first.
So here I have a class.
I'm going to extract it.
So I invoke the
modularize for factoring.
And you can see that it offers
to pull four classes out
into this new module.
And that's because this class
depends on three other classes
recursively.
And it'll also
pull along with it
resources and manifest entries.
This is the ideal case that
I bet you will not actually
encounter with your own app.
Here's a more realistic example.
So I'm going to try to pull this
activity into its own module.
And here you can see
it's pulling a lot.
And we have some spaghetti
because my class depends
on this class which
then, you know,
utils class, which
is then pointing it
to some other stuff.
This is real spaghetti.
And so what you have to do
now is start deciding where
to cut the spaghetti, right?
And so you invoke this.
It creates the new code.
And then you would
have to actually fix
the code afterwards.
So we have an initial
version of this in Canary 1,
but this is a feature we're
very much still working on.
We've also improve
the APK analyzer.
So what I can do here is load in
a APK that is a release binary.
Right.
So last year we launched this
and we had a lot of support
for resources.
This year we've added a bunch
of support for code and DEX.
So first of all I can drill
into the DEX system here.
Let's see-- so I can
right click on a class.
And we disassembled
the byte code for you.
You can also notice that the
package name here is a.a.a.
And I promise we didn't
write the code that way.
That's because this is
a ProGuarded APK, right?
So ProGuard has gone and
shrunk all the symbols
down to something very short.
But now we have this button for
loading the ProGuard mapping
file.
So when I do that--
I've got to find my
ProGuard mapping file.
When I do that, you can see that
we now show the original symbol
names instead, as you're
drilling around in the Dex
file, which is pretty handy.
[APPLAUSE]
There are some
more features here.
I can right click
and, for example,
generate a keep rule, which
is handy when I'm comparing
debug and release binaries.
By the way, we have this compare
button up here on the right.
And I notice that, hey,
I need to actually keep
this class for the release.
Or, conversely, I
might be surprised
that this class is in
the release binary.
And so I can
right-click and say,
show me the usages in
the ProGuarded code
to help me identify what
it is I need to get rid of.
We have another feature for
APKs and that is APK debugging.
So the way this works is that
either from the welcome screen
or from the File menu here,
you can point to a random APK--
let's see-- I don't
know why it's not
showing my home folder.
I think I'm having
network issues.
Well, this is very sad.
All right.
I'm just going to
talk through it.
So, basically, if you're
not using Studio--
if you're a game
developer-- we give you
a way to just point to an APK
and we make a shell project
for you based on the
APK analyzer, where
we show you the sources
inside APK on the left.
And then we let
you map sources--
the Java source code as well
as the shared libraries.
We let you drop in a SO
with debuggable symbols
to stand in place for
the optimized one.
So I'm really sad
that didn't work.
All right.
Next, I should talk
about the profiler.
This is a really, really
big feature for us
with lots of people
working on it.
And here's how it works.
So I've already
started running my app.
It's an image app.
In fact, you probably
saw this in the keynote.
I started running it.
And so the way
the profiler works
is I can now open
up the profiler tab
and it will attach
to the process--
all right, no connected devices.
I'm going to run it again.
It's very unhappy.
I'm going to just kill the
emulator and start over.
This is really exciting
television, isn't it?
All right.
We should work on making that
system image boot faster.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So here we have it.
And no connected devices--
wow.
You know what, I say we--
oh, there we go.
Here we go.
Whew.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
OK.
So the way this works is that
it's attached to this process.
And it's showing me what's
happening with the CPU, memory,
and network.
And so let's go and make some
stuff happen in the app, right?
So I'll click on an image.
And-- wow-- network
is very unhappy.
OK.
All right.
Super slow-- OK.
Anyway, it works, because if we
look in the background here--
and I accidentally clicked
on the memory profiler-- here
we have the CPU,
memory, and network.
You see these little
purple dots up here?
Those are my touch events.
You can also see the
activities happening.
Activity-- things like
stopped and destroyed.
It's very small.
But it's basically listing
activity names up here.
So let's start with the network.
This is a timeline
I can scroll in.
So I'm going to click
down in the network area.
And here I can see the network
traffic and radio traffic that
happened in this time interval.
I can zoom in on
something like this
and it'll show me
the network calls
that happened during that time.
And I can click on a
particular network request
and sort of see it
and the call stack.
And the way this works is
that we instrument your app at
build time.
And so you have
to opt into this.
So you go to your run config and
there is a profiling tab where
you enable advance profiling.
So, basically, we look
for uses of usages
of HTTP url connection.
And so if your
app is using that,
or anything based
on it-- like Volley.
And we also support OK HTTP
now, as of 3.0 Canary 1.
[APPLAUSE]
We've also added
support in Android 0
for basically doing this
instrumentation on the fly.
So you don't need to do any kind
of build time instrumentation.
So that'll be enabled
in an upcoming build
of Android Studio.
All right.
So that's the network profiler.
Let's look at the CPU profiler.
All right.
So I'm going to,
again, click in here.
And here I can see
the thread activity.
So I'm going to jump
to be live again.
And then I'm going to do
some stuff in the app.
So I'll click on this image.
Actually, I forgot
that what I want to do
is start collecting samples.
So I'm clicking on the
recording and now it's
gathering more
information and then I'll
do some stuff in
the app like that.
And now I'll stop recording.
OK.
So now the timeline--
it's showing me
here that during this interval
we have more information.
And I can stop.
I can click on a particular
thread I'm interested in.
So the thread displays
in the middle here.
And we can see that AsyncTask
3 looks pretty interesting.
So I'll click on that.
You can see a flame
chart on the bottom here.
And this is actually based
on ranges that I select.
So I can narrow my focus on what
I'm particularly interested in.
And we also have a--
actually, that was
the call chart.
This is the flame chart.
And we also have top-down
and bottom-up displays
of the frames.
So here I can sort in descending
order of method calls,
for example.
So that's the CPU profiler.
And last, but not least, we
have the network profiler.
So, again, I'm going to go live.
So I just want to reiterate
this point about this timeline
keeping all data.
I think, I was told, about
five megabytes per hour
is what this costs.
So now I'm going to go live.
And we're going to
start looking at memory.
So the first thing I'll do is,
I'm going to go inside the app
and I'm going to ask it to
clear all of its caches.
And then I'm going to go
into network profiler.
And I'm going to click on
the garbage collection.
So now we have sort
of a good baseline.
All right.
So this is showing you the
memory of the app right now.
And let's start collecting
allocation stack traces.
This means that any
kind of allocation
that happens in the
app-- we're going
to record where it was done.
And the reason for that
will be obvious in a second.
And now I'm going to do
some more memory-intensive
activities in the app.
You can see, in the
background, the metrics
are scrolling as it's
realizing the heap is larger.
And now let's go in and grab a
heap dump with this down arrow
here.
So now it's fetching
a heap dump.
And that should be fast.
Yeah.
So here we can see,
basically, a summary
of the objects in the heap.
If I click on, for
example, the bitmap class,
there's 76 bitmaps.
I can see those objects here.
I can click on a bitmap class.
And, just like in
the old heap viewer,
I can now start chasing
down the references
if I want to look for a leak.
But it can also see
which bitmap this is.
Or, if this was allocated during
my allocation tracking run,
I can see the
allocation stack trace--
where this object came from.
And for other classes--
for example, string--
yes, we show the actual string.
So that's the new profiler.
We hope it makes
your apps better.
[APPLAUSE]
And now I'm going
to turn it over
to Xav, who's going to show
you how we're working to make
your builds perform faster.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank you, Tor.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Let's start with the
new Maven repository--
finally.
I know a lot of you
have asked for it.
So the url is maven.google.com
and starting with Gradle 4.0
milestone 2 that was
released yesterday,
you can just use
the Google shortcut.
So it's much easier and you
don't have to remember the url.
We are publishing all the super
libraries and the Gradle plugin
now, exclusively,
through the repository.
And we've uploaded all the
previous versions of the super
library-- not of the
Gradle plugin yet--
that will come soon.
So you can just start
using the repository
even if you are not
using the new artifact
that we released yesterday.
Then let's talk about
build preferments.
We know it's a big problem
for a lot of developers
and we spent the last few
quarters really focusing
on that a lot.
So the first thing that
I want to talk about
is making a lot of
task more incremental.
So we looked at the biggest task
that takes the longest to run.
And we looked at what we could
do to make them incremental.
So the Java compilation is
actually part of Gradle itself.
And, as of Gradle
3.5 it's enabled
by default and it's stable
incremental compilation.
It doesn't yet support
annotation processor,
but it's something that we're
working with the Gradle team
to fix.
Dexing in the plug-in
3.0 is incremental
on a per-class basis and works
with [INAUDIBLE] Dex as well.
So that will make
a big difference.
And then, finally,
APK packaging-- in 2.2
we released that as
an incremental package
so that we don't
have to recompress
entries that, you know, didn't
change from the previous build.
And then we have a couple of
tasks like resource processing.
We are working on
it using APD 2.
We've made a lot of progress.
We are planning to release that
for 3.0-- for the final 3.0.
And then shrinking--
if you're using
shrinking in your own
debug build in order
to get below the
multi-dex limit,
we have an incremental
shrinker that
allows pre-dexing and is faster
than just running ProGuard.
So you can use that just for
de-bug and do a [INAUDIBLE]
with ProGuard anyways.
So the second thing I want to
talk about is the build cache.
So Gradle, in 3.5,
released a build cache
that works at the task level.
So Gradle already looks at
the hash of all your inputs
to see if the task
is up to date on it.
And now it can use that
hash as a key in the cache.
And if the task needs to run but
there's an entry in the cache,
you're just going to
get the output directly
from the cache, rather
than re-run the task.
So it will be faster.
It should be stable
in Gradle 4.2
and enabled by
default at that point.
There's three run
version of the task.
The first one-- of
the cache, sorry.
The first one is local.
So it's good when you're
switching between branches.
And you can enable it today with
Gradle 4.0 using --build-cache
on the property.
And then the other one
is the distributed one,
sharing build cache with your
teammate and your build server.
For that, you need
a storage backend.
So they have a
reference implementation
on top of Hazelcast
that you can use.
Gradle Enterprise, of
course, we bought it.
And As a very simple API if
you want to generate your own
backend.
So the Gradle plugin
3.0 alpha 1 does not
have a lot of cache
that are, right now,
mapped as cacheable--
only a couple of them.
But we are planning to
roll out more of those
and most of them by
the time 3.0 is final.
So that should make
a big improvement.
Now a lot of developers
are asking us, OK,
how should I
organize my project?
You know, how many
component-- how many modules?
And how does that
affect performance?
So, generally, more modules mean
you can go around, you know,
lack of incrementality
in some of the tasks.
But it's also useful for
other things, like code reuse,
for example, you know,
if we want to share code
across different
application, if you
want to have better control
over API and dependencies--
like, your business
logic should probably not
have access to some random UI
from work that you are using.
But, in terms of performance,
with caching in particular,
then having more modules
mean more chances
to have a cache sheet,
and that's better.
And, also, there's something
called compilation avoidance
that was introduced in Gradle
3.4, that you're now using.
I'm not going to talk about it.
James [INAUDIBLE] will have
a talk today at 5:30 talking
about building up speed--
build speed-- and they'll
talk about it at that point.
Now we know that a lot of
developers have told us,
well, I'm adding more modules
and now my build is lot slower.
You know, what gives?
So this is really what
we focused on a lot
in 3.0, so I want to
talk about that now.
The first thing
that we looked at
was the startup cost
of the build, right?
That configuration
time that happens
every time you want to do
a build or every time you
want to sync.
So we got a project
from a developer.
It's about 135 modules,
220 dependencies.
And in 2.2 it took almost
three minutes to configure.
And that's pretty terrible.
So we finally fixed that
down to 10 seconds into 2.3.
But even then, we are
still doing things
that we shouldn't be doing,
like preserving dependencies
for all the variants,
even though you may only
build one of them.
And we could not
really fix it properly
without a lot of new APIs.
So in 3.0, with Gradle
4.0, we finally fixed that.
And it's down to two seconds.
We still have some
room for improvement.
There's some things that
are not quite parallelized
but we'll do that later.
So the other thing that we
looked at was, you know,
bottleneck when you
have a lot of modules
and you want to
parallelize the build.
And, again, it's something
we work very closely
with a greater team.
They did a lot of
new APIs for us
and, finally, we can fix that.
So let's look at
an example here.
Here, on the left,
we have some tasks
that belong to an
app that consumes
a library and the task,
now, on the right.
So let's go through what
happened in the build.
And, you know, we're
going to, basically, build
all the elements of
the app of the library
and then package them in
a big zip file-- the AAR.
And then we're going
to unzip that AAR.
And we're going to consume
it, you know, on the app.
So you can see,
zero parallelism--
that's pretty terrible.
So, again, with those
new APIs that we have--
now we can publish all
those elements of the AAR--
and there's what,
like 14 of them--
separately, instead of just
having to publish the full AAR.
And the build, instead, can
look something like that.
As soon as the manifest
of the library is used--
is available-- we can
keep building the library,
but we can start
building the app too.
And then you have
better parallelism.
And, notice, also that we don't
build the AAR at all anymore.
We don't unzip it so the builds
are more efficient that way.
And then, finally, Gradle
4.0 has some additional APIs
to do parallelism
inside a single module.
We're not quite using them yet.
But we're going to
start using them soon.
All right.
Let's talk about some
new build features.
Oh, and I want to
mention that, you know,
it's just the first step.
We're not saying
we're going to--
3.0 is going to fix
everything, right?
It's something we're going
to keep investing a lot in.
And it's just like a first step.
OK.
So some new build features.
First thing I want to talk about
is Java 8 language features.
So it used to require jack.
We announced a few weeks ago
that jack is [INAUDIBLE].
In fact, in 3.0, jack
is completely removed.
If you try to enable it, it
will tell you don't enable it.
The DSL is still there so
that we have a proper message.
All you have to set up is
the source compatibility
and the target compatibility.
So the build looks
something like this, right?
We go from Javac,
which generates
Java 8 class Bytecode, to a
converter that converts that
to Java 7 class Bytecode,
transforms, and then dexing.
The transform is things like
ProGuard, [? InstantRend. ?]
But also you're on
transforms, potentially
if you use the transform API.
So, just as a heads-up,
later-- probably in 3.1,
we're going to reverse
those two steps
and do the conversion after.
So if you have
custom transform, you
need to update them to
Java 8 class Bytecode
as soon as possible.
The second feature
I want to talk about
is dependency management.
So there's a lot of
changes here in 3.0.
You're probably
aware that if you
have an app and a library
right now, the library--
the app only consumed the
release version of the library
always.
So on the right here, you
have the configuration
of the library--
debug and release.
And then you have the
configuration of the app--
debug and release, and
then compile and packaging.
And you could kind
of like go around
that by manually setting
up, you know, debug compile,
and then targeting debug.
And that would work.
But if you use flavors, it
doesn't quite work very well.
Now in 3.0, things
are more complicated
because for
compilation avoidance,
what we have on the
library side is we publish
two configuration per variant.
So now we have debug
API element and debugger
runtime that are meant to
be used on the other side
by compile and runtime,
which were renamed
to match the Gradle ones.
So the good news is that we
finally fixed that in 3.0,
thanks to new API in Gradle.
Now the step goes automatically.
We don't have to manually
try to make that work.
So let's look to see how
that works at a high level.
Basically, we have
the ability to set up
attributes on this
configuration object
and Gradle will
automatically match them.
So we created an attribute
on build type for you
automatically.
And then debug matches debug and
then release matches release.
If you have flavors, same thing.
We create a new
attribute for the flavor
and then bluedebug matches
with bluedebug automatically.
You know, you don't
have anything to do.
It is done automatically.
Now, of course, if you don't
have the same number of flavor
everywhere, it's
going to work too--
like, if you don't have
them in the library,
bluedeblug is going to match
with debug automatically.
The attributes are
actually optional.
However, if that's the
other way around-- if you
have a library with
flavors, but you
don't have flavor
in an application,
then it's just
not going to work.
And you're to get a build
error and you have to fix it.
So we have a new DSL--
it's called flavor selection.
It's not variant-aware yet,
but we're going to do that--
where you basically
tell the build, look,
I want to pick blue
instead of orange.
And then it just works.
Now if you switch to 3.0,
and you have flavors,
you're very likely to run into
that error saying, you know,
hey, flavor dimension
name is now required--
which you may already be
doing with two different ones
but not if you have
a singular dimension.
So fixing it is very
easy, right, you know.
That's your code, roughly.
And then you fix it with
that and that's done.
You don't actually
need to put it
in like flavor one
or flavor two block
because there's
only one dimension.
We can just fix that for you.
So the big question is, why
do we force you to do that?
Why can't we just pick up
a random default value?
So let's go through an example.
Here we have an app.
And the app requires
debug orange.
And then we have two libraries,
one of them with two flavors--
blue and orange-- and the one
with strawberry and orange.
Now you can already see that's
not quite the same orange,
right?
And we just don't know.
So when the apps
says orange, it's
like, I don't know
which orange you want.
So that's why we ask you to
name those flavor dimensions.
Because we're going to use that
as the name of the attribute.
And then the name
of the attribute
is actually color blue,
color orange, and then
fruit strawberry.
And then we can make
the right selection.
And it's the same thing, right.
Here, to make it work, you
have to set a flavor selection.
And, in order to do that, you
need to not just give us blue,
but you need to give us color
blue so that we can properly
set that new attribute
on the configuration
and then it just
works out of the box.
OK.
Let's talk about instant
app a little bit.
So let's say you have an app--
you know, it has a few modules--
an app module, with that,
the application module;
some library modules.
And then you want to make
some of those libraries
as features for
your instant app.
So the first thing
you're going to do
is change some of those
plugins to be not library,
but be feature.
It's a new plugin
that we released.
It's part of 3.0.
And what's nice about
that feature plugin is
that it uses the
attribute mechanism
I just talked about so that
it publishes both a AAR--
or at least the content
of the AAR for an app--
and a feature APK.
So when an app says, hey,
you know, I depend on you.
Give me your artifact.
It adds to the attribute
saying, I'm an app.
And then it's going to link
it to the right configuration.
And it's going to consume
the feature plugin, you know,
as an AAR.
And when you have
another module that
is an instant app-- and the
goal of that instant app module
is not to build anything.
It's just to package--
to grab-- all of
the features APK
and make it into a bundle that
can be uploaded to a phone
or to the Play store.
Then the feature
plugin will actually
build a feature APK--
something that can actually
be distributed to your phone as,
you know, instant app feature.
And that way you can
really share code
without having to
do some weird stuff.
It's just the regular
module that you had before--
just change the
plugin, and that's it.
If you want more information
about building Android apps,
there's a talk at 3:30 today
that I encourage you to watch.
And, with that, back to Jamal.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMAL EASON: All right, so test.
So now you've developed
and built your application.
Now it's time to test.
So we offer inside
of Android Studio
is a new performant Android
emulator, which we actually
released about a
year and a half ago.
So if you haven't tried it since
then, I highly encourage it.
It's fast and exciting.
But after launching
the Android emulator,
we found about two pain
points from developers.
One-- developers want to try
out their end-to-end flow.
What's the experience
look like, for instance,
when my app-- when my user
actually downloads my app?
Or, perhaps, what's
the experience
of an in-app purchase?
There was no way to test this.
The second pain-point was
around Google Play services.
It seemed, every
release, there was
some lag between Google Play
services and the Android
emulator.
So to that, we added the Google
Play Store to the emulator.
[APPLAUSE]
Now this seemingly small step
was actually a lot of work.
What we did was actually add a
lot of quality and performance
enhancements to ensure we
had a great experience when
using the Play Store
with the emulator.
Along with that, we
also added support
for OpenGL ES 3.0,
which, hopefully,
will help you accelerate
your testing as well.
And, lastly, we
added proxy support.
I know some of you have
Enterprise networks
or unique ATT support.
Now we have a UI system
that manages that.
So I want to talk about
the impact and implications
of adding the Play Store.
So we've always shipped the AOSP
versions, or the Android Open
Source Project versions
of the system images.
What this allowed you to do
is have unfettered access
to both the operating
system and your app
by having elevated
privileges in root access.
But by adding the
Google Play Store,
we actually have a
new variation of this,
called the Google Play edition.
What this means is now we
actually digitally sign
the system images.
But that prevents you
from having root access.
So if you want Google
Play and Google APIs,
just use the Google
Play edition.
But if you want the deep
analysis and root access
ability, you still have the AOSP
version that's also available.
One additional thing I want
to talk about for the emulator
is actually this app
bug reporting system.
So we heard from some
of you, like, hey, I
want to have a quick way to
take a bug report so, perhaps,
I can share with my
colleague or my QA team.
So now, with one
or two clicks, you
can create a bug report for
emulator, take a screenshot,
have some space
to do a repo step,
and put that to your QA team.
So that should make it quicker
for you to do development
on the emulator.
Lastly, for those of you who
do Android Wear development.
As you heard, with
Android Wear 2.0,
we now support devices
with rotary support.
So we added a feature
inside the emulator for you
now to test that all inside
the Android emulator.
And, lastly, about debugging
is around the Layout Inspector.
So, as you saw
from Tor's demo, we
have a rich, new
Layout Editor, which
allows you to add new constraint
layouts and new themes
and styles for your application.
But many times you might have
a problem with your layout--
something's the wrong color, or
something's invisible, or gone.
So we actually launched a
Layout inspector last year.
But with this release
we added new capability
for better search and better
organizational properties
to help debug your
layouts for Android app.
So, lastly, optimize.
So as you heard
during the keynote,
we talked about Android vitals.
And what this really is about
is about the system health--
about your phone
and the apps on it.
And the way we think
about this is actually
sort of a continuum of
information that's available.
So as you get the system
health information
now available through the Google
Play console or Firebase--
now you have a list
of sort of symptoms
of what might be going
on with your application.
And now you can pop
into Android Studio
to have a deeper understanding
of what's going on
and have a root case analysis.
And, as Tor showed you,
at the core of this
is the Android profiler.
So I hope you take advantage
of all these various tools
to understand--
ranging from, again,
the CPU profiler to understand
what is going on with your CPU;
the memory usage to
understand what's going on
with your memory profile
of your application;
and, lastly, the
network profiler,
to get a deeper
understanding of what's
going on with your network
traffic of your app.
The last topic I want to
talk about in optimize
is around APK size.
So, as you heard on
the keynote yesterday,
we announced Android
Go and this initiative
around making Android
optimal and smaller.
So, many times
with your APK, you
might have legacy code or
things going on with it
you may not sort of remember
putting into the app.
So with 3.0, as
Tor demonstrated,
we've now added
additional capability
into the APK analyzer.
So, again, I invite
you to use this
in your typical
optimization flow.
As demonstrated,
we added support
for instant apps, better
Bytecode support, ProGuard file
mapping, and much more.
And, lastly, I want to call
out a big feature around vector
assets.
So I'm a big fan of using
vector assets myself.
And it's a great way to
optimize your application.
But if you must use a
bitmap or a raster image,
we added WebP support
inside of Android Studio.
And what we found is, if you
convert from PNG to JPEG,
you can save upwards of 25%
in your file size, which
would be a huge saving for APK.
So, again, if you right
click on any PNG instead
of-- or JPEG inside
of Android Studio,
we will auto-convert it to WebP.
And if you want to edit it, you
can actually convert your WebP
back into PNG.
And, with that,
that's Android Studio.
So we talked about
a range of features
from develop, for adding Kotlin
support, or better Java 8
language support;
better instant app
support inside the build system;
adding the Google Play Store
to the emulator;
and a whole suite
of optimization tools for you.
And with that, that's our talk.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]